aujourd'hui on se retrouve une nouvelle
vidéo et comment c est du coup il va
rendre ridicule en limitant si bien
[ __ ] les a mais comment allez-vous moi
ça va extrêmement bien aujourd'hui
attention je l'annoncé pour pâques des
gens va jusqu'à la fin en espérant
rigoler c'est une vidéo blabla mais j'ai
envie de vous parler un peu à coeur
ouvert et en plus j'ai des trucs très
important à vous dire alors ce qui reste
vous n'allez pas être déçus on sait
qu'ils savent pas y'a pas longtemps j'ai
fait une sorte de casting où je
demandais aux gens d'envoyer des vidéos
d'eux qu'ils se présentent pour que
peut-être j'aille par surprise leur
rendent visite chez eux il ya eu huit
gagnants de ce concours il y en a eu 1 à
paris un à nantes 1-1 marseille en
suisse en belgique en guadeloupe et un
au canada et un homard vous comprenez
pourquoi je suis fatigué c'est que j'ai
enchaîné toutes ces destinations
d'affilée pendant quinze jours à prendre
des avions presque tous les jours
attendre d'innombrables heures dans ces
[ __ ] d'aéroports de merde j'ai
accumulé au taux de fatigue qui est
légendaire mais d'un autre côté j'ai
vécu le truc le plus incroyable de ma
vie c'est sûr et certain alors pourquoi
je fais cette vidéo blabla que j'ai deux
choses à vous dire une bonne et une
mauvaise nouvelle la mauvaise c'est que
en revenant du maroc
j'ai compris que mes élèves avaient pris
un gros coup de sac
donc je dois les hydrater toutes les
heures et la bonne la mauvaise nouvelle
chance parlement une mauvaise nouvelle
en fait c'est un mal pour un grand bien
c'est que cette année je prends des
vacances mec
oui oui et ça fait très longtemps que
j'ai pas pris des vacances enfin si j'en
avais pris je crois il ya deux ans une
semaine mais à chaque fois comme je vous
ai dit je me force à faire des vidéos
d'avancé parce que j'ai peur derrière
mettre en ligne parce que j'avais peur
qu'on m'oublie j'avais peur de plus est
au top chez pas quoi les peurs de mère
de youtube heures je vous assure et
youtuber son angoisse est vrai beaucoup
de ça mais cette année voilà je me bats
contre ce truc là et je décide de
vraiment prendre des vacances parce que
je trouve que les derniers mois ont été
géniaux j'ai fait plein de choses
géniales j'ai découvert des trucs
géniaux j'ai parlé de truc qui me font
kiffer en fait c'est des mois où j'ai
été vraiment parfaitement sincère donc
je peux partir en vacances en est en
paix avec moi même
en gros je prends un mois de vacances
c'est la première fois depuis sept ans
que je fais simple comme vous je prends
des grandes vacances comme vous sauf que
j'avais j'ai toujours un peu d'avancé
sur mon planning de vidéos donc en fait
les vidéos s'arrêteront le vert le 12 ou
15 août je crois donc en fait vous aurez
un trou de deux semaines et pas de un
mois voilà en gros la mauvaise nouvelle
c'est les deux dernières semaines d'août
il y aura pas une vidéo de squeeze mais
la bonne nouvelle quand je vais revenir
de mes vacances
la vidéo qui va sortir ce sera la vidéo
des 10 millions mec la vidéo je crois
que j'aimais pas relié ce que j'ai dit
au début a ça en fait la vidéo des 10
millions c'est ce que je vous ai dit au
début le tour du monde où j'allais faire
des petites surprises à des abonnés à
travers le monde
et puis après celle ci il y aura juste
un best-of et ensuite ce sera les
vacances pour moi quoi il y aura plus
rien après le best-of jusqu'à la vidéo
des 10 millions d'abonnés qui sortira
vendredi 21 août à 18 heures bref une
bonne nouvelle ne vient jamais sans une
autre bonne nouvelle c'est pas du tout
ça le proverbe il n'y aura pas une mais
deux vidéos spéciale 10 millions
d'abonnés où il se cache et votre joie
ya css en gros pour les 10 millions
d'abonnés
la première vidéo ce sera un clip
musical c'était génial à faire je les
fais avec bien évidemment montrichard
bino martin qui est un beatmaker aussi
quelqu'un qui sait mixer bref un petit
big up à martin parce que on en a chié
sur cette musique juge en effet pas vu
vraiment mais je voulais vraiment faire
le tout le mieux possible et je suis
très content du résultat et apprécié de
la musique c'est subjectif vous pouvez
aimer ne pas aimer mais en tout cas le
clip ce sera les images de mon tour du
monde les plus belles images quatre
minutes des plus belles images de mon
tour du monde à huit destinations
différentes avec lui personne différente
donc je pense que ce sera vraiment sympa
je pense que l'image va vraiment bien
retranscrire ce que j'ai vécu en fait
pendant ces quinze jours avec ces gens
et la deuxième vidéo du coup ce sera en
toute logique la version vlog de ce trip
de quinze jours donc ça va durer entre
30 et 50 minutes on a commencé par paris
avec williams suit très pressés parce
qu'en plus on a eu la chance de tourner
pendant la finale de la coupe du monde
on l'a en vidéo on à ce moment mémorable
on gagne la coupe du monde vingt ans
après incroyable on est ensuite allé à
nantes la juste une photo avec charlène
que j'ai rencontrés là-bas on ensuite
allé en belgique pour rencontrer noé et
on a fait de la montgolfière je me suis
bien fait caca dessus c'était très
effrayant aventure vous verrez tout ça
dans le lobe un oui vous verrez ce fou
après ça on allait en guadeloupe pour
rencontrer kim j'étais jamais allé là
bas j'ai halluciné de la sympathie des
gens et surtout des iguanes ya des
iguanes partout et je savais pas donc du
coup j'étais en extase devant les
iguanes tout le temps à partir de là ça
commence à être très intense et avait
été au qui réalise la vidéo du
le clip des 10 millions qu'ils aient des
p'tits cracks agents fassent mentir de
temps en temps comme le montre cette
vidéo puis direction montréal un peu
plus haut pour rencontrer samuel j'étais
pas aller là-bas depuis les blogs 2 août
de l'année dernière j'étais très content
d'y retourner c'était super sympa et
puis même s'il y avait une grosse pluie
[ __ ] les québécois vous êtes tellement
gentil c'est abusé on a ensuite retourné
à de l'autre côté du globe à genève en
suisse pour rencontrer laetitia et là on
a fait du bateau j'ai vu parfois le lac
léman et puis j'ai ensuite fait de
d'hélicoptères et c'était c'est fou mais
j'ai hâte que oui ça vous imaginez même
pas assez horrible on est ensuite allé à
marseille dans le sud de la france pour
rencontrer inès jetez pas aller là bas
depuis 12 ans je croise était souverain
a quitté marseille du maire qui dit mer
dit petit bateau dit petit port aussi et
on va pas se mentir c'est très sympa et
on a terminé par le maroc on a rencontré
une fille du mont brita c'était une
journée incroyable j'étais jamais allé
au maroc donc j'ai découvert une culture
ans puisque est très différente de la
nôtre donc c'était hyper hyper hyper
épanouissant c'était fou chaque moment
passé avec chacune de ces personnes
était très précieux et très enrichissant
pour moi là vous avez vraiment un aperçu
de 1 % de ce que je viens de vivre mais
c'est important pour moi pour justifier
cette fatigue et cette pause que je me
dois de prendre là cette année et puis
aussi bas pour vous dire que voilà la
vidéo de 10 millions enfin les vidéos de
10 millions elle pourrait travailler
elle moins être belle et c'est tout ce
que je voulais je veux vraiment
remercier les gens comme il se doit avec
avec cette vidéo des 10 millions et je
pense que j'ai réussi tout cas je suis
content de partir en vacances en me
disant que quand je reviens c'est cette
vidéo là qui sort parce que beaucoup de
retard elle aurait dû sortir il ya un
moment on est aux 11 millions déjà trop
tard je lave où je pouvais pas rêver
mieux en terme de vidéo spéciale 10
millions quand j'ai eu l'idée en janvier
je me doutais pas que ça allait être
aussi fidèle à ce que je voulais en fait
et aussi bien foutu bien réalisé et
voilà je suis très très content je vous
disais je fais un gros des buts mais je
suis rentré hier en fait au moment où
cette vidéo et du coup j'ai encore le
voyage dans la tête ça lui sinon à part
ça
ces derniers mois ont été incroyables
sur youtube
je pensais pas que ma chaîne youtube
pouvait encore plus marché qu'avant et
surtout pouvait encore plus marcher
alors je fais moins deux vidéos et que
je fais surtout des trucs que j'aime
c'est assez d'argent faut être là vous
m'avez mis dans la stratosphère c'est
hallucinant et d'ailleurs je suis
content parce que prendre six mois de
vacances ça me permet de redescendre un
peu de me reposer d'avoir de nouvelles
idées de prendre du recul par rapport à
internet à youtube et tout et ça va être
très bon pour la rentrée en fait je suis
j'ai jamais été aussi stable dans ma vie
que actuellement en fait ça fait
vraiment du bien en fait les gens se
doute pas de ce que youtube heures peut
ressentir en fait en dehors des vidéos
que même s'il est là il sourit tout doit
tout le temps allait bien quand tu
lances la caméra est ouvert en fait des
fois tout va pas forcément bien ce que
je veux dire c'est que moi là j'ai la
chance que tout aille bien et la
redescente qu'on va y avoir une
redescente parce que la vie c'est des
hauts et des bas j'ai pris une grosse
gifle mais pour le moment mais c'est
génial parce que je suis très content je
vous dis à bientôt même si vous voyez
dans cinq jours dans une autre vidéo
puis en signant le best-of dix jours
mais moi là je j'arrête de tourner c'est
mon dernier tournage avant un mois ça
fait très bizarre
merci pour ces derniers mois merci pour
toutes ces expériences tout ce que je
dis c'est hallucinant et puis je le dis
tout le temps mais je me suis obligé de
le dire c'est tellement important trou
de le dire j'ai besoin d'extérioriser ce
dont je me sens pas me comprendre sa
puce ou coupables de ville ça conserve à
matthew allez les gars allez on s'en va
pour guy chateau non pis
[Musique]